y su nombre botánico es Eichhornia crassipes.
En Nigeria, esta planta también es conocida por otros nombres.
Nombres asociados tanto a eventos históricos
como a mitos.
En algunos lugares, es llamada babangida.
Babangida hace referencia al ejército y al golpe de Estado militar.
Transmite miedo, restricción.
En el delta del río Níger, esta planta también es conocida como abiola.
Cuando oyes abiola, recuerdas las elecciones anuladas
y te transmite "sueños hechos añicos".
En el suroeste de Nigeria,
la planta es conocida como gbe'borun.
Gbe'borun es una expresión yoruba
traducida como "cotilleo" o "rumor".
La palabra "cotilleo" sugiere: transmisión rápida, destrucción.
En la zona de Nigeria en la que se habla igala,
la planta es conocida como kp'iye kp'oma.
Cuando oyes esta palabra, piensas en la muerte.
Se traduce literalmente como "muerte de la madre y el hijo".
Me topé con esta planta en 2009,
poco después de trasladarme de EE.UU. a Nigeria.
Había dejado mi trabajo de corporativa en EE.UU.
y decidí dar un gran paso,
un gran paso basado en la convicción
de que había mucho que hacer en Nigeria
en el ámbito del desarrollo sostenible.
Así que allí estaba en 2009,
a finales de 2009 para ser exactos,
en el Tercer Puente de Lagos.
Miré a mi izquierda y me topé con esta imagen impresionante.
Había barcos pesqueros
atrapados en esta maraña de jacintos de agua.
Me afectó mucho lo que vi.
Pensé:
"Estos pobres pescadores,
¿cómo van a llevar a cabo su trabajo
en estas condiciones?
Y entonces pensé: "Debe haber alguna forma".
Una buena solución con la que se proteja al medio ambiente,
quitando de en medio estas malas hierbas,
y se consiga transformar esto en beneficio económico
para las comunidades que se han visto más afectadas
por la invasión de esta planta.
En ese momento se me encendió la bombilla.
Investigué en profundidad para conocer mejor
los usos beneficiosos de esta planta.
Entre ellos, el que más me impactó
fue su uso para artesanía.
Pensé: "¡Qué gran idea!"
Me encanta la artesanía,
sobre todo, la artesanía que tiene una historia detrás.
Pensé: "Esto puede introducirse fácilmente en las comunidades
sin la necesidad de contar con destrezas técnicas".
Se me ocurrieron tres sencillos pasos para una gran solución.
Primero: Meterse en los canales y sacar los jacintos de agua.
De esta forma, se crea acceso.
Segundo: Secar los tallos de los jacintos de agua.
Y tercero: Convertir los jacintos de agua en productos.
El tercer paso era todo un reto.
Tengo experiencia como informática
pero no en artes creativas.
Así que empecé mi aventura
averiguando cómo aprender a tejer.
Esta búsqueda me llevó hasta una comunidad en Ibadan, en la que viví,
llamada Sabo.
Sabo se traduce como "el barrio de los extraños"
y la comunidad está formada mayormente por gente
del norte del país.
Así que, con las plantas secas en mi poder,
tenía bastantes,
fui de puerta en puerta, buscando a alguien que pudiera enseñarme
a transformar estos tallos de jacinto de agua en cuerdas.
Me enviaron a casa de Malam Yahaya.
Sin embargo, el problema es que Malam Yahaya no habla inglés
y yo tampoco hablo hausa.
Pero unos niños vinieron al rescate
y nos ayudaron a traducir.
Así fue como empecé a aprender a tejer
y a transformar estos tallos secos de jacintos de agua
en cuerdas largas.
Con estas cuerdas largas listas
ya estaba preparada para hacer productos
y ese fue el principio de las colaboraciones.
Trabajé con fabricantes de cestas de mimbre para idear productos.
Contando con todo esto, estaba segura de que
podría llevar este conocimiento
hasta las comunidades ribereñas
y ayudarles a transformar su adversidad en prosperidad.
Cogimos estas plantas y las tejimos, transformándolas
en productos que pudieran venderse.
Teníamos lápices, posavasos,
bolsos, cajas para papel.
De este modo, ayudamos a las comunidades
a ver los jacintos de agua desde otra perspectiva.
Los jacintos de agua podían ser valiosos,
estéticos, duraderos, resistentes y elásticos.
Cambiamos los nombres y la forma de ganarse la vida.
De gbe'borun, cotilleo,
a olutosan, narrador.
Y de kp'iye kp'oma que significa "muerte de la madre y el hijo",
a Ya du j'ewn w'Iye kp'Oma,
"proveedor de comida para madre e hijo".
Me gustaría terminar con una cita de Michael Margolis.
Dijo: "Si quieres aprender de una cultura, escucha sus historias.
Si quieres cambiar una cultura, cambia sus historias":
Desde comunidades como Makoko, Abobiri, Ewoi,
Kolo, Owahwa o Esaba,
hemos cambiado la historia.
Gracias por su atención.
(Aplausos)